et nous sommes avec bruno attal
président fondateur du collectif touche
pas à mon flic et antonin peschard
avocat et enseignant à sciences po paris
bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france bruno
attal le problème de la police et la
justice
tout d'abord le plein pot la police
tu prends mon ritchie on estime que qui
n'est pas garde des sceaux n'est pas qui
n'est pas ministre
il est resté avocat il est resté là-bas
des voyous il a envoyé un message assez
clair aux délinquants
c'est le ministre des voyous se fait
applaudir dans les maisons une
comprennent ce qui se passe il est
arrivé en disant que la gorge
il est arrivé en disant on avait un
sentiment d'insécurité donc les citoyens
doivent regarder ça avec eux avec des
yeux et ben ali est donc le nouveau
syndicat france police policiers en
colère en blanc de la démission de
monsieur dupont moretti déjà pour
plusieurs conflits d'intérêts notamment
dans la sphère théo ou sauvages pernaut
fille que j'avais de beauté les
spectateurs à la regarder
on a vu que monsieur en mauricie avait
commis trois infractions dont la
violation du secret professionnel
l'insulté la police en disant qu'on
avait commandé fond c'est le petit théo
alors que maintenant on sait très bien
que c'était une supercherie à cette
affaire parce qu'ils n'avaient ni a pas
eu viol voilà je pense que ces promos 26
le plus mauvais ministre de la justice
de la vème république donc penser que
madame taubira est là la meilleure mais
non monsieur dupont moretti fait
beaucoup mieux monsieur pêcheurs antonin
peschard qu est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça absolument pas vous
comprendrez que quand on a un ministre
de la justice quels qu'ils soient qui
vous dit que après les déclarations tout
à fait scandaleuse le problème de la
justice de la police et la justice qu un
ministre bien recadré en vous disant que
l'un sans l'autre ne peuvent pas
travailler efficacement
c'est un appel au dialogue et que ça
fait des années qu'on appelle au
dialogue les policiers et qu'il reste
dans les dents dans une guerre de
tranchées en expliquant que le problème
ce sont les anti flics
ce sont les avocats ce sont les
magistrats du fonds alors que tous ces
gens oeuvre pour essayer d'instaurer un
dialogue un dialogue entre les citoyens
la police et nous qui côtoyons les
policiers les commissariats quasiment
tous les jours avec les comportements de
policiers qu'on connaît je regrette que
des syndicats comme le vôtre monsieur
touche pas à mon pote à mon flic avant
policiers pardon continue de d'alimenter
de cultiver ce dialogue ce nom dialogue
où nous avons raison vous invite à
écouter nous donc nous pouvons
fonctionner vous ne pouvez pas
fonctionner sans nous mais vous ne
pouvez pas fonctionné ce temps la
justice
et vous vous comportez comme des
procureurs et des juges du fond monsieur
vous nous et elle vous pensez vous
pouvez fonctionner sur la justice mais
pas du tout j'ai pas attaquer la justice
dans son ensemble la justice était faite
d'hommes et de femmes pour la plupart
qui essaient de faire leur travail mais
quand les prisons sont pleines et qu'on
ne peut pas appliquer comment la loi
c'est la loi finalement elle est assez
sévère si on regarde bien mais elle
n'est pas appliquée
alors effectivement ce cet avocat ma
demande du dialogue avec grand plaisir
mais nous aussi on a des morts mais si
on a des blessés
alors pendant que vous vous parlez vous
jacasser eh bien nous on ne nous on est
blessé et en plus souvent parler donc
deux hameaux cachée de comportement de
la police
mes collègues à 99 % sont des gens
exemplaire qui fait un travail à un
excellent travail est effectivement
maintenant avec les nouveaux réseaux
sociaux on est filmé h24 on essaie de
nous faire des proches pattes on le voit
dans la sphère est clair on sait que
c'est maintenant que c'est un montage
fait par l'extrême gauche dans la ferté
au constat que c'est une manipulation
quelconque les violences policières il y
en a forcément yona à la marge mais
voilà c'est exactement le genre
d'avocats qui me demande de dialoguer et
finalement qui affirme des choses alors
que lui il est bien tranquille dans son
bureau pendant tout on est en première
ligne et nous on se fait blesser et on
se fait chez les messieurs alors sur la
sphère est clair sur les rassure qu'on
ait vu les mêmes vidéos bruno attal
l'histoire d'un gars je vous invite à
aller à touche pas mon prix et vous
regarderez ce qui s'est passé exactement
ces 3000 policiers qui se sont fait
enfermer et que c'est clair a tenté de
voler leurs matraques et monsieur éclair
a menti sur la deuxième vidéo tout ça
vous l'avez sur touche pas à mon flic
effectivement tous les médias veulent
passant dans paris parce que tous parce
que tout simplement c'est une réalité on
est à présent des trucs et notamment les
cas porter atteinte à la présomption
d'innocence
on a aussi un ministre de la justice qui
mike et demi sur les white sox
effectivement nous on est là c'est le
pot de terre contre bon ce n'est pas ce
qu'on a vu nous sur ces vidéos géré à
damas dans le ministre de l'intérieur a
précisé que le problème venait d'une
faiblesse des moyens de la justice
est ce que c'est ça qui pose problème
selon vous entonnant peschard le
problème et moyens de la justice est un
problème qui dure depuis des dizaines
d'années c'est vrai que en france on est
largement en dessous tu pitié des
budgets moyens en europe
est ce que c'est ça qui va changer le
comportement de la police excusez moi
monsieur vous compariez biais de ces un
peu de politique en disant que c'est
l'extrême gauche qui a fait des montages
vidéo comme si la france était dirigée
par l'extrême gauche henry d'autant plus
que votre votre votre association
monsieur je ne vous ai pas couper votre
association et affiliés à un syndicat de
police qui est manifestement d'extrême
droite il n'y a qu'à voir le profil de
ses dirigeants et leur passé politique
monsieur vous ne pourrez pas le
contester comme vous l'avez fait sur
d'autres plateaux mais le problème des
moyens de la justice pour en revenir aux
véritables débats qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui le problème de moyens de la
justice monsieur moretti et moi en tant
qu'avocat je peux vous dire que ce
n'était pas forcément très favorable à
cette nomination et pourtant pas
monsieur moretti il a négocié et il a
obtenu une augmentation sensible des
moyens de la justice
votre problème en fait c'est que vous ne
supportez pas que lorsque vous
interpeller quelqu'un il ne fasse pas 15
ans de prison
soyons honnêtes c'est ça votre problème
vous vous comportez comme des juges du
fond votre travail est de protéger les
citoyens et oui il ya des policiers
encore la semaine dernière j'étais en
garde à vue ça ces extraits
man bien passé j'en étais extrêmement
heureux et on ne peut que rêver de cela
mais dans 90% des cas monsieur en garde
à vue ma collaboratrice est une femme
d'origine maghrébine
je peux vous assurer que dans 90% des
cas monsieur à paris elle a des soucis
parce que quand elle arrive on lui
demande sa convocation et pas sa carte
d'avocats allez me dire qu'il n'ya pas
de souci dans la police le budget a
bondi en quatre ans de 8% pour la police
rien que pour cette année on a atteint
les 9 milles 90 magistrat c'est ce qu'a
déclaré eric dupond moretti est ce que
vous constatez vous bounoua talent sur
le terrain qu'une augmentation des
moyens la police a mais nous ce sont les
parents pauvres de tous les ministères
on travaille un peu de temps mais dans
des locaux déplorable des voitures
dégueulasse mais j'aurais quand même
répondre comment à l'avocat sachez cher
monsieur que nous nous sommes
l'administration la plus plurielle c'est
à dire avec une vraie mixité qu'on a
réussi nous alors je sais pas si dans
l'ordre des avocats vous avez autant de
maghrébins ou de personnes issues de
l'immigration
donc vos petites réflexions
effectivement moi je ne crois pas une
seconde à ce que vous me dites notre
police et républicaine est ensuite trop
chère madame
effectivement on est nous n'avons pas vu
la même vidéo sur l'affairé car il est
tout à fait raison parce que vous n'avez
pas vu la vidéo de la police on ait vu
juste qu'une version
ensuite quand vous m'attaquez qu'un haut
dirigeant stade extrême droite on n'a
aucun compte à vous rendre et c'est pas
vous de passer le curseur de savoir qui
est à droite et l'extreme voir ou en
tout cas vous êtes bien caché dans votre
bureau
dans les beaux quartiers effectivement
voulait nous donner des leçons mais moi
mes leçons les leçons je les prendrais
pas de vous charmer si on la ferme et
clair ce n'est pas le sujet de notre
débat on va parler de 12 établissements
des peines planchers un peu refuse
eric dupond moretti est-ce que vous
vous comprenez ce refus antonin peschard
oui alors absolument le principe des
peines
c'est que un juge doit prendre en compte
le l'infraction qui a été commise et
lorsqu'elle est caractérisée dont on
rencontre la personnalité de celui qui
l'a commise lors c'est la raison pour
laquelle les policiers sont plus
lourdement sanctionnés lorsqu'ils sont
sanctionnés pour avoir plusieurs
exemples à vous donner ils sont rarement
sanctionnés mais ils sont lourdement
lorsqu'ils le sont et c'est normal
maintenant je pour monsieur dit qu'il ya
des moyens d un manque de moyens dans la
police et je fais le lien avec votre
question je le rejoins pour avoir vu des
voitures de policiers qui sont dans des
états déplorables pour voir un manque
d'effectifs qui est tout à fait alarmant
pour une république comme la france
néanmoins aujourd'hui le le problème de
ces moyens doit être résolu à la fois au
niveau de la justice mais aussi du
ministère de l'intérieur
le problème c'est qu'il n'est pas là il
est entre le direct entre la police et
la justice
les peines plancher ou vont contre les
droits fondamentaux
vous parlez du dialogue entre la police
justice manquant les planches et s'il
vous plaît j'aimerais connaître votre
avis bruno appel benoît talent sur les
peines planchers évidemment mais
finalement peut-être se poser la
question si si on souhaite des peines
plancher c'est tout simplement qu'on
comprend que la loi n'est pas acquis et
c'est à dire pas l'habitude est coupable
et reconnu coupable eh bien il n'y a
jamais de sanctions et nous on voudrait
qu'il ya de réelles sanctions après
monsieur le bilan de l'oubli c'est à
dire qu'avec qu'il ya de réelles
sanctions mais les prisons sont pleines
vous avez dit magistral qui nous disent
qu il n'y a pas de place en prison donc
on va on va tout faire pour aménager la
peine que l'individu soit 5 solide donc
si on a passé par les peines plancher
oui pourquoi pas mais encore une fois
faudrait se poser des questions
commencent et icloud 48 places de prison
en france
c'est un réel problème en aient les
moyens effectivement les moyens de
mettre palette
c'est vraiment déplorable en forme est
là mais l'administration de ça je peux
vous dire qu'on se met dans les
conditions mais je ne voulais pas
d'accord surmontera les conditions
le mot de la fin pour vous tenir péchard
qu'est ce que vous répondez sur les sur
le manque de moyens
à écouter alors sur le manque de moyens
je vais de manière très objectif
le ministère de la justice et le
ministère régalien le moins bien dotées
de maintenant là on peut trouver un
terrain d'entente monsieur attal au
niveau de monsieur dupont moretti notre
ministre sait que l'essentiel du budget
l'augmentation du budget qu'il a obtenu
de la part du président de la république
va être destinés aux prisons aurait donc
monsieur attal beaucoup plus de places
de prison dans quelques années qui
permettront peut-être aux magistrats du
siège
en effet vous pouvez jouer du pipeau
temps de vous voulez supermétro réagi
siège paul ii peut faire de faire de
faire exécuter les sanctions et au
demeurant je précise cela pour le lac la
culture de vos téléspectateurs qui ne
sont pas essentielle savoir mais les
peines ne sont exécutés qu'à la demande
des procureurs de la république pas des
juges du fond monsieur donc le problème
vient de vos supérieurs hiérarchiques et
pas de la magistrature du fonds
merci beaucoup entonna béchard avocat et
enseignant à sciences po paris et merci
à vous bruno attal président fondateur
du collectif touche pas à mon flic
excellente soirée merci merci